- Hi.
- Come on down!
- Hello, hello.
- It's like you
and Henry called each other
with the color palette,
I like it.
- We did, we did.
- Do you know Henry or Melissa?
- I've met, you know, I
mean, I've seen your work.
I'm excited to see "Scream,"
which I hear is insane and so good
and I can't wait to check it out.
(audience cheering)
Woo.
And I mean, this is a legend.
- I know.
- AKA the nicest person
I've ever met in entertainment.
- I know.
- Wow, thank you.
- I'm telling you, it's you and Dolly.
- You're not gonna make me cry.
I don't have waterproof mascara on.
- Oh, my gosh, I did too.
But it didn't help.
(Kay chuckles)
So we'd mentioned Henry's
love for Patrick Mahomes
and you know him.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Can you get him in there?
Can you get a dinner maybe out of there?
Get a little help?
- I have covered him for a long time,
going back to Texas Tech.
You're from Texas.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I looked at your menu.
Henry, I wanna help you out.
First of all, we gotta talk ambiance.
- Yeah.
- The way to a quarterback
and through his stomach is
through his offensive line.
We gotta get those invites out.
Those big boys have to come over,
so you better get to cooking
up a lot of that chicken.
- Are we talking Kelce?
- [Kay] No, his offensive line.
But Kelce can come too,
the more the merrier.
- Okay.
- Also, he puts ketchup
on everything.
- On everything, that's Texan.
- Is it?
- Alright Patrick, yes!
- So that's what you need to do.
- That's Texan.
- I'm talking on the steak,
on the banana split-
- I will have bottles up
and down the table.
- I love how proud I am
of that moment.
- Yes.
(Kelly chuckles)
Yeah.
And he loves Whataburger, which he brought
to Kansas City-
- It's Texan!
- Which is a Texas thing.
- Which is Texan.
- Here's what we'll do.
We'll make a video and I'm not
gonna send this to Patrick.
We're gonna send this to Brittany
Mahomes, his lovely wife.
That's the way to do it.
- That's smart.
- Thank you.
- That's the way to do it.
What's up, Brittany?
- And Kelly Clarkson
wants to come.
- Yeah, I was like,
"Can I get invited?"
I wanna come.
- Yes.
- I saw the video.
- I wanna come.
Melissa that wants to come.
- I mean, I'll come.
- Yeah, yes.
- And Winkler.
- I have room.
- [Kelly] "I have room."
Henry's like, "Everyone's
coming to my house."
- And we have ketchup, Patrick.
- We have so much ketchup,
for anything you want.
- We love ketchup.
And that's how it's done.
You're welcome, Henry.
- So, Kay, you are one of
the only women solo hosting.
That's incredible,
sports shows.
- Yeah.
- I know that that's kind of a bummer
at the same time saying that but,
is it tough?
- It really is.
Thank you for saying that.
- I always hate saying that.
- It's like it's 2023.
- I know, it seems like such a bummer
to say.
- Yeah.
- But also, you know, a pioneer
for other girls watching
that wanna accomplish this.
(audience applauding)
You're one of the women
that's actually making
that a dream come true, that
they have the possibility
of that 'cause they're seeing it.
Is it tough though still?
- There are challenges
and I think, you know,
they say that football's a game of inches.
I think sometimes being a woman
in sports is a game of fine lines.
- Yeah.
- Be assertive.
Don't be too aggressive.
Be nice and friendly.
Don't be too, too charming
though, that's bad.
So it's also, you know,
something that I struggle with
that's sort of hard is
how do we celebrate women
who do awesome stuff in sports
but not putting a spotlight
on it so it becomes this thing
that we're like looking at all the time.
Like, I wanna normalize the fact
that-
- That's what I'm saying,
yeah.
- I'm just here to do my job.
So there's this fine line
that I'm always walking
that I find challenging.
But that said, it's a
result driven business.
It's like any industry out there,
if you work hard and sort
of don't label yourself
then you won't have those limits.
- Yeah, it is cool though,
knocking down doors for future
women that wanna do that.
So, your show isn't just the NFL,
which I think is so cool and clever.
So what all do you cover?
- Everything and anything.
I mean the, the daily show is a grind
as you know.
- Yeah.
- It's all about the
people who work with you,
the people who support you,
like you're awesome audience here.
So it's a heavily based interview show.
I love bringing different
voices on to be as inclusive,
informative, and entertaining
as possible, so.
- Yeah.
- We don't do cooking segments.
I mean, your crew back
there, Kelly, is well fed.
- They're mashing on those muffins.
- I think that they're trying
to get me to be a cook.
Like once I signed up for this show,
there's so many cooking segments.
They were like, somebody
was like, "Help her."
- Henry's gonna put you
to work at that dinner
with Patrick Mahomes.
- I know.
If you want it to be edible, don't.
- No, but I just want you to be a guest.
- Okay, I like that.
I'm, look, I'm invited-
- Henry you are-
so serious about this.
- It's on video.
- I am.
(audience cheers)
- I'll bring tequila.
- Are you covering the Kentucky Derby
as well with the show?
- Yes, I will be.
So you know, it's the draft season,
so that's in Kansas City,
if you wanna...
- I'm going.
- Okay, I'm going too.
- Friday.
- Let's figure out our outfits, Henry.
- Okay.
(audience chuckles)
- And yeah, so the draft will happen,
then the Kentucky Derby,
which I've never been to.
- I've never been too and I've
been invited so many times.
It always happens at the
same time, like in Spring.
So it's always like a busy time,
but I've always wanted to do it.
Ever since I saw my "My
Fair Lady" as a kid.
- Of course.
- Yes.
- So, I always do-
- I wanna wear the hat.
- I've worked in football
for over a decade,
but now it's cool 'cause
I have my own show.
I have a lot of freedom with FanDuel
to talk about whatever I want.
So, Melissa and Henry,
you're welcome to come on.
- Thank you.
- I love that.
To cover different sports as well.
- Yeah.
- That's really, really cool.
Awesome.
Well everybody "Up & Adams,"
which by the way is the coolest title.
- Thanks.
- I love that.
"Up & Adams" airs weekdays
on FanDuel TV and YouTube.